it is time for hatred mail if you've
never heard hatred mail here's a preview
of what we mean by hatred mail so what
if the president's been accused of
sexual harassment 15 times or that he
paid hush money to a porn star at least
he never wore a tan suit patriot mail
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom so sometimes hatred mail is
homophobic sometimes hatred mail attempt
to emasculate me or a mask you laid hat
or emasculate our audience sometimes
hatred mail is anti-semitic sometimes
hatred mail is conspiratorial and
references various conspiracy theories
today's is all of those things in one
let's take a listen to it David Pakman
is a tool of the NWO everything he
stands for is anti America I'm convinced
this worm has no testing claice look at
his limp wrists flopping all over the
place david has actually been busted
several times before such a Schilling
Schilling shekel homos
so the anti-semitism is talking about
shekels right of course the the new
Israeli shekel NIS is the currency of
Israel so Pat you didn't even know this
I didn't know the naive wide-eyed
bushy-tailed Pat didn't realize that
when people talk about shekels about 90%
of the time it is a sort of thinly
veiled anti-semitic reference of some
kind so that's that's the anti-semitism
here talking about me shilling for
shekels or whatever homophobia is saying
I'm a limp-wristed homos hom o J which i
think is just a typo so we've got
homophobia emasculation claiming I have
no testicles which I think means
testicles but just again misspelled
probably okay and then conspiracy
theories right referencing the NWO which
if you don't know about that it's the
New World Order also kind of intertwined
with
Alex Jones one world government
conspiracies so this is hitting all four
of those highlights I think this may be
the best hey treat male of all time you
have all the bases covered in relatively
few words actually it's quite quite
pithy in a sense yeah it but he says
you've been busted several times before
I mean oh as a game I've been busted as
gay as if that's something that like if
you're gay you've been caught is the
idea I think underlying this where it's
something that one would try to it's
like getting caught having committed a
crime in the mind of many hatreds it
being gay would be something you would
try to hide and you could be caught
being gay this is in their mind by the
way I don't want this taken out of
context in one of those highlight reels
made of where it sounds like I'm saying
these things nobody nobody would ever do
that in our audience of course okay if
you want to make the hatreds cry if you
want to send a middle finger to the hay
tree it's you can use the coupon code
hey tree at 40 for any membership at WWE
pakman.com and that will save you 40%
and 177 hey tree 'it's will cry every
time you do that so I suggest you do
that h atri OT 4-0 okay let's move on